hi there
America and other countries I don't know
who's watching none of us will ever
truly know but I want to invite you and
welcome you to backstage beers presented
by our friends at Samuel Adams that's
right folks tonight is a huge deal we're
gonna be taking questions from you via
many types of social media you know all
about them I'm not gonna list them I'm
38
I only know maybe two or three but we're
gonna get into them and you're probably
asking yourself right now
this incredibly attractive well-groomed
very well dressed young man said we I
wonder who he's talking about it's just
him there right now that's right folks
we have a pretty special guest tonight
on Conan and Rory chat backstage and
we're not gonna tell you who it is
because it's gonna be a pretty big
reveal but I I think when when that when
that tall redheaded guy gets out here I
think you're gonna be pretty surprised
too it is because right now you think
you know who it is but you don't
actually know but I'll tell you this
will take their questions the entire
time that we're out here shouting about
Boston that's where we're at we're
actually backstage here at Wilbur
theater in Boston MA I don't know what
the MA stands for cuz I don't do
research but I know it's in Boston and I
think there's only one of those to my
knowledge but if anyone here watching
this is then gonna go to the show and
find out later that you went to a
different Boston that's on you because
we're at Boston MA whatever that is
but yeah thanks for joining us hopefully
you guys have some questions about
Boston I always love to do a little hint
about who the special guest is going to
be but turns out he is from Boston so if
you have questions specifically about
Boston or him go ahead and ask him
despite the fact that you currently
don't know who it is maybe people have
some questions for me let me go ahead
and go to this fake iPad and see if I
can find any questions here just me
scrolling through all the questions here
we go okay
dog Maddox on YouTube asks come to South
Africa that's not a question at all you
get a lot of different people tuning in
that's what
dogmatix thank you for your time and for
your demands
here's one for me Eric Raven on YouTube
asked Murray what is the best part of
doing stand-up I'll tell you what more
than likely it's the pure joy and the
actual connection that you make with a
lot of different people who are you know
if they're going through a lot of
different stuff me included and I love
getting up on stage with them in the
crowd and honestly I've been throwing
things at them a couple nights ago we
were you know they were on this tour now
a couple nights ago we were in Atlantic
City and I took the stool and I threw it
out into the audience and I honestly
thought someone would have caught it but
I did hurt I did hurt a few people that
were in three or four rows because it
kind of hit someone's face isn't it
rolled back
that won't happen tonight in Boston I've
been told by the crew here and everyone
that's kind of working on the tour to
not do that again and there's a pending
lawsuit so I'm told
but I'm on tour right now so I can't
worry about that I got something this to
get into why do people do that after
they take a sip of some I was you we get
it you like the drink move on you know
what I mean guys get it here's another
one for me
med BC on YouTube ask is Rhys Koval
related to the chart that measures the
spiciness of peppers that's a very good
question am I related to an inanimate
object in many ways yeah don't tell my
wife I said though he's great she is
great she's watching she's watching now
and now I'm gonna hear about that later
on if we can edit that out that'd be
great it is life thank you all right
let's see what else we got here ooh-hoo
this is probably not a question for me
it's probably for our guests but since
they don't know who that is
I'll go and take it because that guest
could be literally anyone and we're
gonna we're gonna get him out here
pretty soon because it is his tour
that's a little clue that's a little
clue Condon and Friends and Who am I
gonna bring out friends or Conan we'll
see
it could be either one of those people
on Friends is a person it's not a
description of a group of people this is
kind of an interesting question hey Kahn
YouTube asks hey Rory
what's Conan's favorite food I like that
give Conan's question to me I will
answer that I would say lobster roll but
that seems hacky because that's what you
want me to say just because it's Boston
but I won't say Lobster all very basic
cheese pizza no cheese on top you ever
see someone grab a slice of pizza take
everything off of it and then just eat
the pizza and just the sauce and then
and then they don't like I don't even
like crust that's Conan and it's not
it's not becoming it's very gross it's
gross that he's like that we don't have
a great relationship
I'm kidding we have a great one I can't
wait to get him out here and have him
answer questions that I'm pretty sure
you guys will ask him about what is my
favorite food
lobster roll all right what else we got
going on here you know this is actually
my fifth time in Boston I was in a film
called
I feel pretty a lot of people say it was
Amy Schumer's I feel pretty I say it was
Rory Schumer's I feel pretty because I
feel like my name should be in there
somewhere and I was here for a month and
a half and I'll tell you what I learned
this city is very bikable if you were if
you were if you live in Boston MA and
you have the opportunity to bike they've
got these bikes that you can just rent
out on the street get on those and get
around town you're gonna get a workout
and you're gonna be helping the
environment and that's the kind of thing
I like to do you can't just wear a
sweater like this unless you're a pro
environment okay what else we got here
Oh Amanda here you go
Amanda on YouTube asked who was your
favorite comedian and favorite one
working today big fan of the Marx
Brothers that's not one comedian but
that is that those are comedians and my
favorite comedian working today
contractually obligated to say that
is Conan O'Brien very good at stand-up
very good at comedy I've watched his
show a few times through the years when
I've been on it and I've liked those
episodes a lot really enjoyed enjoyed
those someone said Rory come to Russia I
just don't see the tour going there any
time soon but we did go to Atlantic City
and that felt like a world away so
tonight just a reminder tonight we're
gonna be at the Wilbur theater that's
where we are right now I don't know what
you guys can see what those steps right
back there those are the steps that all
that Conan and Friends end up going up
to go out on stage and tonight and I
didn't double-check any of this I just
took the crews word for it but tonight
we're doing two shows because the first
20,000 tickets sold out that quickly
that they said we got to throw another
show on and see if we can sell 20,000
more tickets and then me being me I go
time out time out
are you telling me we're gonna perform
for 40,000 people in Boston and they
said yes so when you do the Facebook
live make sure people know that if they
want tickets they need to get those
tickets because 40,000 people were on it
instantly to get those tickets
someone here just said they googled they
googled the capacity of the Wilbur
theater and they lied I was lied to it's
not 20,000 each show but it is a lot
15,000 or something like that see what
other questions we have here if you guys
have questions and you're on Facebook
right now yes oh I'm gonna look up
so-and-so I went to high school with why
not also send us a question maybe ask me
or whoever my special Conan guest might
be what it was like growing up in Boston
I think there's a few here just so you
guys can sort of get a taste test of
some questions to come mousey on YouTube
asks who is Conan's favorite employee
now I would say technically
I am NOT an employee but I do know that
he does have a lot of strong feelings
for my involvement in this tour and he
even said that this tour would not have
taken place had Anaya
I not have agreed to have been on it so
I don't know if anyone here watches
Conan regularly and you you love fun
facts but Conan said the tour wouldn't
happen without me so that's pretty neat
what's up dope
I thought you guys said something okay
what's been my favorite stop on the Lea
Lea Orly on Facebook said what's been
your favorite stop on the tour so far
just so you guys know to get you up to
speed this tour just kicked off in
Washington DC last Thursday and Friday
excuse me November 2nd and I I so far
I've loved all the shows we've been in
DC we've been in Atlantic City and we've
been in Detroit and Detroit was pretty
pretty impressive I got a standing
ovation at all three of those shows
which I thought was kind of intense I
don't ask for that kind of thing I also
don't require that kind of thing but
ladies and gentlemen our special guest
has made it and I know you're probably
just as surprised as I am from Conan and
Friends Conan O'Brien thanks one of the
friends all right Rory Rory we haven't
met yet
Rory yeah I fly in a different plane
yeah yeah yeah this is fun no one's
asked this question but I'll just go and
put it out there and I say one thing
before you get started okay this takes a
second you gotta go for one of the
funniest easily funniest standup
comedians I've seen in years you make me
laugh on stage and I'm crying laughing
at your foolishness you're absolutely
sure this backstage and I'm sure you
feel the same way about me I have always
enjoyed being around you
offstage and I think on stage you make
great strides towards success I think
terrible what I said was just so filled
with love and
what you said was you all miked up moist
yeah I'm all rainbow doesn't know these
are microphones yeah that's how you're
able to hear us yeah we got some
questions here that we were getting
through this Facebook live event
sponsored by Sam Adams here at backstage
beers with Conan and Rory Scovel you
want to you want a great question let's
make this a regular show by the way
backstage beers with Rory and Conan we'd
probably get free beer don't you think I
think we would get free beer with
situation are you where someone else is
interviewing you deals does it feel hey
take it easy how does it feel to be in
the hot seat all of a sudden well I kind
of like it actually less control I look
at you there with your fancy computer
this is a tablature now someone asked
and I'm not making this up to name all
the planets and their capitals that
would be great
well there's Pluto everyone knows you're
from Boston yeah literally everybody
knows that and be on YouTube wants to
know what's your favorite thing to do in
Boston oh can you do in Boston well a
bunch of things I love to do of course
you can catch a game that is way too
much work that's a loud slurp people do
that though right like when you're the I
like slow and you interview you must
leave space for the guests I'm teaching
you okay you're young your these are
Winwood I go for the sip maybe not yet
all right I'm gonna give you a signal
when to slurp you got it if you can
catch a game at Fenway well then you've
really that's just magic its best
ballpark in the world I love that you
know what's gonna be fun that I'm gonna
do soon well oh I bet this is gonna
light up your day I'm gonna go to the
Sam Adams brewery and we're gonna shoot
a remote there there foolish enough to
let me and my crew go to the same
immense brewery and I think I'm going to
get free beer I really do from the Sam
Adams brewery I think so and we're gonna
shoot a segment and that'll be on the
show be a lot of fun but they should
probably look at my other remote
segments we usually break things and
cause a lot of damage you won't do that
you won't down at the Sam Adams brewery
I think I will I'm gonna break stuff
there it's a mistake too
me in it's their mistake if Sam Adams is
watching and yes you are sponsoring so
you're probably looking into it he is
joking he's gonna be very respectful of
the space he's a hometown hero Boston
boy done good coming back home he's
gonna show a lot of respect to Samuel
Adams I think I'll know was the one who
rode around good warning everyone that
the British I was Paul Revere was that
Paul Revere he does not have a beer I
don't think so you don't have a beer get
out of here that's how I was raised
that's an incredible rhyme yeah yeah
well maybe it was I don't know what Sam
Adams did I know he didn't he wasn't you
know what did he do I don't know he's
one of those guys is like I did
something I made a good beer yeah that's
the important thing and that's more
important than winning the Revolutionary
War well in the long run we need my hero
who did that because history you know
you don't know much about history do you
nobody wrote it down
hey we know they wrote it down and you
refuse to read it someone asked who you
are mausi on YouTube I already brought
this up they wonder who your favorite
employee was of all time of all time oh
man that's a hard one I've had so many
great ones I think sonam obsessed you
and my assistant she's gonna be one of
my favorites is she the favorite I'm
gonna give it to Sona okay I'm gonna
give it a soda Daniel M vids on YouTube
what a real name I don't think so but I
don't know we'll find out we have a way
yes coming to get you
Samuel embed yeah Daniel in vids well
I'm looking for Samuel Oh Daniel wow
that guy I know just wants to know what
your favorite Batman movie is my
favorite Batman movie is the one from
the 1960s the Batman movie with Adam
West the real Batman
none of those gothic [ __ ] like did I
say go ahead go ahead have yourself a
nice little quiet
hold on try that again all right but I
did almost choke it takes me four hours
to drink one half of a beer yeah I just
do some tiny slur you are a very you're
an alcoholic who paces himself that's
what I admire about you that's the
discipline I have you Joe on YouTube
wants to know Conan who is your favorite
Simpsons character as we all know Conan
invented the Simpsons Conan invented the
Simpsons and yeah still on the air he
had that he walked away from his just
someone else handle that I've got other
you notice to make I invented the
Simpsons and created it invented it
didn't think it was going anywhere after
a couple seasons so not only that I walk
away sold his stock as we didn't sell it
I gave away my ownership of the Simpsons
I had like an 80% stake
they gave something to Matt Groening for
doing some drawings I forget what he did
I gave it away I think those are the
those are the kind of moves you make you
know when you're young and you're just
playing cards and you say I'm at get me
in the biz yeah and I'm sure several
people told you that the show was gonna
do quite well for it was already doing
quite well there you go so I'm now in
terrible financial shape and Matt
Groening and a bunch of other people who
did nothing have it all yeah ridiculous
but yes his question I liked writing for
mr. burns he was my favorite character
yeah he was just fun he's he's like a
million years old he has infinite wealth
he's just fun if you're a writer you can
you can create all kinds of fun stuff
for mr. burns a frail frail man very
frail
yeah very frail um did you get anything
get into anything in Boston today did I
J mix it up did you get out there and
bet I did you bet I did you walked
around Newbury Street what I like to do
is I wear a tweed cap and I like to put
it on backwards and I like to walk
around and just dare someone to hit me
in the face Bostonians love that I'm not
but that kind of like boxing style does
feel very
Boston oh and I give this is how people
in Boston fight they do yeah and but
that's what I did I walked around all of
downtown Boston today I went into the
North End and I just have my cap on
backwards
and I'm bobbing up and down and I'm just
hoping some guy takes a swing at this
old Apple and I'll come on I'm like
johnny-come-lately you have a pirate
laughs thank you and you have a pirate
laughs and a ski instructor sweater
it's an odd combination someone wanted
us to take the tour to Russia is that
gonna happen to you
are you okay go to Russia I would go to
Russia Wow
like you're supposed to say my career is
too hot my careers too hot I don't have
time I've got other backstage beers
episodes very very very many it's a good
move for you what is your favorite food
to grab it is everything favorite baby
monster roll don't say that I'm not
gonna say that oysters don't say that
not gonna say it I don't know what else
they serve here
Oh Michael are you talking about this is
really kind of talk about those two
things I come to Boston exclusively the
McDonald's here is better than any other
McDonald's and I know you think it's all
the same it's not Boston McDonald's is
better it sounds a little pandering
are you sure that the McDonald's here is
better than everywhere much better the
Buckley McDonald let's go to the polls
you don't have anyone to do that for us
oh sorry we can't cut it about anybody
come back from the polls we're still
here McDonald's yeah right okay
McDonald's but what do you eat like what
is the Boston food where you go I'm
gonna go get that go get me you know
what I always do I always take my
parents too
they love the Capital Grille there's one
up on route 9 I take them there they
love to get themselves a steak that's a
great place to bring your parents and my
brothers and sisters join me and this is
more I'm from Boston and very local then
yeah I take my parents up to Capital
Grille at 9:00 I know it's ridiculous
that's across the street from the only
restaurant my parents there was only one
restaurant we got to go to a restaurant
once a month when
was a kid and it was Tony's Italian
villa and it's long gone but it was such
a big deal as a tree that was a treat we
would go there and it's it's in that
same part of route 9 and when I was a
kid we could each have one soda one soda
I grew up in the 1920s and times were
hard wait that's the 30s you know all
but I feel like times have just always
been hard no they're pretty good now
well I don't keep up with stuff no you
don't you don't read history I only sit
with my tablature and don't tell me what
you've been looking at pornography for
the last five minutes well that's where
all the questions come all right we're
gonna wrap it up with one last question
here there's Celtic 7:45 on YouTube
thoughts on the Red Sox winning well I
was at Game five I could only make one
game took my son to Game five in Los
Angeles
I saw them win the World Series that was
the most I've never seen that happened
before I know they've won four titles in
my lifetime I've never seen them never
been on the field when they clinched a
World Series I was on the field when
they clinched which is illegal I was
actually I was right next to the
third-base sewer so actually it was an
invalid win I ran out prematurely so
they should probably look into that
sounds like they're gonna be doing a
redo but I'll tell you what that's gonna
be you and your sports talk with you
don't read in the sports talk but if you
guys did enjoy this this Facebook live
backstage beers with Conan O'Brien and
Rory Scovel
don't be afraid to tune into my sports
chat radio talk sports sports sports
eSports the titles not great but I we do
get into some we do nothing about that
works I do wait which one is football
quick that's the sport where they
there's a different two teams with
coaches
locker rooms we're gonna go yeah but
thanks for joining us we have other
cities go check out team cocoa see if
we're coming near you